we might be drunk we
might be drunk as long as we
are hanging out you know we might be
drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk we might be drunk
hey we're here folks this is it we might
be drunk not yet we're about to crack
open a new bottle of something i've
never heard of that pop
i love the pop it's a little natural
wine i don't even know what color it is
but
natural aren't all wines natural no some
are or
this i don't know that i don't know a
lot about wine i know the difference
organic wine
that all i know about this wine is the
hangover's so much less
oh great so that's huge yeah it tastes
good some of it is funky you get like an
orange wine
it's kind of trendy right now i found
out about this when we were on the road
with
aziz it would be me phil hanley you know
whoever uh will silvence who didn't
drink but he'd be along for the ride
yeah
mateo whoever but uh he would order
these weird funky wines and they tasted
really weird and good and we were never
hungover
why would he be we'd be a little
hungover
yeah that's the thing about that's the
thing about uh
hanging out with rich people is they
teach you a few few things about look at
that
class wow it looks like cider wasn't it
yeah learned a lot from these uh you
know these rich people who took us on
the road and
you know they like put the spoon on that
side the fork on this side it was all
felt titanic did you figure that on
titanic
i didn't remember it you know it was
like going to etiquette school again
what do you think cheers cheers
tell me what you think smells kooky
it's got a bite it's kind of fun right i
like it
i like it well dude let's do red next
time i'm a big wino guy i
like the drunk that wine gives you it's
a good loopy
you it's you sometimes can get
belligerent on bourbon you can get a
little
crazy on tequila oh yeah wine you just
get sloppy and silly and i love that
yeah yeah but that the red with the
tongue the thick
wooden tongue and the purple teeth and
the hangover is bananas the hangover can
be rough it's not as bad with this
oh great and it still gets you nice and
[ __ ] up
so i like it i'm into it carlin was a
wino
what george carlin went to rehab for
wine is that right
yeah he would just wow and i'm sure
there was other [ __ ] going on yeah
a little nose candy i think as well he
was a wino
i had nev i've never heard him talk
about drinking that's fascinating yeah
and then it's funny to go to rehab for
wine it feels so romantic
you know it's the only type of rehab
where they're like all right [ __ ] yeah
yeah all right jesus what year
you know it is it is this is nice i kind
of like it
yeah you know they got rid of what was
it prohibition they had prohibition they
said
alcohol was the meth of its day yeah so
they'd just be guys like an
alleyway shit-faced or fallen over or
passed out
interesting yeah like farmers were big
in the booze and they would just get
drunk and lay in hay
yeah that was in that ken burns dock
right yes yes
and how like the barkeeps would run for
office and stuff because they were so
popular
exactly exactly everything was built
around booze like even stand up was like
comics and gin joints and
mafia nightclubs yeah there's something
about it man something about
prohibition too where you're like this
isn't allowed
that's kind of how i felt during comedy
during the pandemic yeah speakeasy we're
like this i'm not supposed to be
i remember like on one of the roofs
somebody took a joint dad no i do have
to put it out and i was like dude none
of this is leaking
yeah exactly we could all die it was
like having a black friend in the 40s
we're on the edge yeah yeah i loved that
part of the pandemic
that's something we'll tell our kids
about like oh turn off your vr
sex worker i got to talk about this
pandemic i was in 30 years ago yeah the
way that you
you know when like your mom would be
banging on your door like dinner and
you're like i'm studying but you were
jacking off
yeah now it's gonna be parenting and the
kid's like [ __ ] a sex robot i'm like
come on just no [ __ ] the sex robot at
dinner come on
all right this is crazy what about um
get some gas i had its show i got we got
free food and it's all coming out
i got the salmon so this is gonna be
rough
we got the white we got the white wine
with the salmon yeah see i like a white
over red because i feel like
it's it's light i feel like i'm just
drinking water
on a crisp day in the sun but this is a
thick one this is a thick white at least
rather like a
yeah this is like a chisholm white right
here this is
thick white it's like a rosie o'donnell
or a kirsty alley
so you uh you didn't have a good set
there though oh
was it rough i mean it's one of those
giant rooms that keeps going and going
so everybody of course sits in the far
back because they don't want to be up
front sure and then it's very stuffy
it's very rich they're all members
the furniture is super nice amber's i
know
brutal i always think of the scene in
caddyshack when dangerfield walks in
and it's like as a kid that's what you
want like you know he walks into the
stuffy country club and he's just
zinging everybody yeah he walks up to
that old lady but you were something
before electricity
all right i feel like that's most of my
life is
is if people were here they'd be
laughing but you guys hate me
but like even at soho i'm like you guys
hate me but if an audience was watching
this on tv
i'd be doing well exactly they're like i
i don't hate you
i'm dead on the inside right and you're
like right i'm taking it personally but
you are
you're miserable you're hot and you're
miserable and you i can let my guard
down enough to perform and bomb for you
people but you can't let your guard down
enough
to crack a smile that's a great way to
put it but again i keep trying
to put myself in their you know italian
loafers
and go okay there's six people here
eight people there's a lot of pressure
on them but they don't laugh doesn't
mean they hate you so i try to give them
the benefit but
they hated me let's be honest you went
on first
yeah that's never easy to crack it open
though now tyler fisher hosted he was
super positive
great guy and talked to all of them but
you know what's tough is
a dark joke with eight people is dead in
the water
there were eight people there maybe 11.
it was rough it's a meeting that's not a
[ __ ] show
i know i know and then the meeting was
it was an intervention to quit comedy
you should not be doing this that's
tough when you have yeah a dark joke for
a small crowd
they look at you this this was my first
few years in comedy they look at you
kind of like
we just don't like you it's not even
it's not the material right
we don't like you yes we think you're a
bad guy because of these jokes you're
like no these jokes don't represent me i
just think this is
funny yeah i'm not this guy like i
opened with a pedo joke and they were
like what are you
crazy and i'm like oh yeah you guys
don't know him can't open with that yeah
i know well it's also like it's like
also you know who ain't making pedo
jokes
pedos yes good point so good point
maybe this is a good sign right hey
right yeah jared fogle is not doing any
pedophile material
he's steering clear of that uh
yeah it's it's interesting i was talking
to harry before the show
producer harry and uh you know he was
that he was asking because we talked
last episode what makes a good comedy
club
because we're saying like these are the
clubs we like we left off acme by the
way i was thinking
minneapolis great club good call good
call but
you know and i'm sure we left off a
million but yeah
uh yeah there's something about
like low ceilings everything that's
everything that makes covid
bad is good for company it's good for
comedy
yeah yeah hot dingy room smokey
low ceiling yeah yeah it's all horrible
it's all bad for
corona yeah great for comedy but
speakeasies that seemed like fun you
know that's the invention
or not the invention but that's what led
to mexico like border towns
because they'd hop the border just for a
cocktail damn yeah that's how it all
started
they hopped the border for a drink
that's how bad people wanted to drink
because there wasn't
blow yet and stuff like that you know
there wasn't like percocet
back then so they had to get creative
and all they had was booze that was the
only way to cut the edge
it's funny that booze is legal because
you see like how dangerous it is
i know i feel like we drank but i feel
like we drink pretty responsibly
yeah now yeah yeah we took a few road
bumps to get there i remember us at
industry parties back
when we were young comics and there was
an open bar and it was like
it was just us like guzzling shots oh
yeah me walking up to someone like
this is you oh yeah i know like i'm the
president of nbc i'm like oh okay
that's true oh man we didn't realize we
were burning some bridges
no no but we were 24 or 26 whatever it
was and also back then there was no
thought of mixing alcohol i was just
like oh i'll take a beer i'll take a
tequila i'll take a red wine
i'll take a jaeger whatever it was he
just took it and uh
the goal was like okay the bar's gonna
close i gotta black out before then
we were not mature it and i think i
don't want to
ever become an alcoholic because i don't
ever have to quit
oh yeah i like it too much to abuse it
yeah
i mean we abuse it probably slightly
sure well it's like a girlfriend
[Laughter]
emotional yeah
now um yeah no you're right we abuse it
a little but
we know where it's almost like comedy we
know where the line is we cross it a
little with alcohol then we we bring it
back
and just like in comedy in 10 years
people are gonna be like and you did
what
that's true yes thank god there's not
documentation of my
college and high school years drinking
oh my god i think it says everybody
they're acting on myself all that [ __ ] i
remember doing prom shows
completely just [ __ ] house wasted yeah
and like guess what
it was your like caroline's comedy club
yeah it would be you'd go on at like 3
30 in the morning
they'd be [ __ ] waste and you're
like what am i i'm gonna pay 25 bucks
what am i not gonna get hammered
exactly i gotta get my money somehow and
they're gonna hate me anyway so i might
as well have fun
sold out room and they're paying us 25
bucks to get home at 6 a.m yeah
yeah and there were some great nights
there were some great nights it would be
great when we didn't know we'd be there
and you'd be like ah
yeah yeah you're an idiot too we both
need a gig
yeah and but it was just fun because it
was a real knife fight that was a real
lesson in
like hey you don't just tell your jokes
you got to be on your feet in the moment
zinging and zang with these you know
horny 18 year old kids with a crust dash
and a boner
you had to really riff and and go off
the the the script
you start bombing you're like all right
who's the nerd they all started cheering
you're like
let me throw someone else under the bus
here oh yeah this guy's a virgin
he just started jerking off he likes her
but she's into this guy yeah that was
always fun they'd be like oh my god he
knows us
yeah those gigs were hell those were
awful when you'd start a show at 5 00
p.m
because you're like on like linda
smith's show oh yeah and then you're
like oh i'm starting at 5 p.m and my
last spot is at 3 45 a.m
this is gonna be a weird night yeah and
you're like i better have a beer now and
then you have another beer
throughout every show until the 3 30.
you show up to caroline's at like 3 30
in the morning without a shirt on
you sure you're on tonight like i'm on
and then burke crasher was like what the
[ __ ]
that's my thing yeah those were wild
times and
no real i mean we didn't think about
consequences it was a fun way to live
there were consequences but we didn't
think about them
that's true now i'm always in my head
like i guess because we're older
yeah and also you can't you're that guy
in your 20s that's all right but you're
that guy in your 30s it's
you're there's you're not a work in
progress anymore right you're
you're the work right right that's so
true
i did a video shoot and it was a pretty
big shoot with a guy i'm not going to
say who it is but we know him well
and we went we did a lunch break and
they're like go wherever you want for
lunch in the city and then come back in
like an hour and he put down like four
beers at lunch
wow and he came back and he was a little
loosey-goosey and they were like this is
not cute anymore like
this we should fire you you're gross
you're pathetic and he was like oh [ __ ]
he thought he was fun richard belzer
yeah it was low on order that was the
shoot but yeah yeah it was uh it was it
was an eye opener for me
yeah that's a problem where you just you
gotta have
a handle on it because yeah it's so easy
not to that's the thing is like
it would be so easy to become an
alcoholic for us because we drink for
free at every club
yep you get bored there's so much down
time
totally i mean that's the thing too you
get off stage and you feel that energy
from the crowd
like say that you crush you get off
stage like i need a drink i need i can't
just like let that feeling go i need
something
or you bomb and you're like woof i gotta
get rid of that no matter
what you're like i need a drink that's
so true yeah
i never thought of it like that it's the
cure-all it's a great drug
great drug it kind of just adapts to you
whatever you need it goes with it you
want to keep partying it's a great night
you drink if you have a horrible night
you drink
back in the day meth was that yeah i
guess so yeah
damn method meth does not look fun if it
look the thing is alcohol can be awful
and you can look awful but can also look
fun that's true
that never looks fun don draper had a
scotch
kings have these chalices with wine in
it so they're still
successful people you know they crack a
bottle of champagne when they sell a big
thing at ford or whatever you know so
there's booze still
in successful places but there's no meth
in like
you know the white house or or whatever
that's a good point i know don draper
was a miserable guy but he looked like
he was having
a good time he had a there was some good
times peppered in but he was banging so
many hot women they're like i know
you're unhappy but this is like high
this is top shelf misery yes yes this is
the belvedere of like sadness here
yeah exactly yeah it's like you say the
the the party from the man
you know you got to separate him and we
saw his man but we also saw the party
yeah breaking bad it's like i know they
were just selling math but even just
like that
just being around it like who'd you
rather be don draper or jesse pinkman
come
on yeah no doubt about it no doubt
no gotta go draper all day pinkman
yeah you got not a fan well he was a
good guy
but uh just a sad life when the
girlfriend od'd
and just the the giant hoodies and the
the outfits yeah i don't know she was
hot dude she was hot that was tough to
see her go
i know are you a big breaking bad guy oh
yeah
seen it many times yeah i always say i
think that changed tv that was so good
it was like i didn't know tv could be
this good
you know who might have been i don't
think he's talked about enough as being
such a great actor on that show is the
guy who plays gus
gus oh chicken guy yeah yeah that guy is
incredible that guy's amazing yeah odin
kirk is great
the guy mike is great everyone talks
about odin yeah and he's a [ __ ]
action star now
i know good for him but that guy mike is
great though the bald guy who's like the
the right man
right hand man of odin kirk oh
yeah yeah yeah that guy's awesome yeah
love that show from beverly hills cop is
he he's the goon in beverly hills cop
wow
he's the guy who killed eddie murphy's
friend in the beginning and he and his
guy eddie murphy
he looks the same he looks like a tough
guy yeah yeah yeah that guy's cool
that that guy used to be on tv a lot
more that just like quiet
tough guy kind of fix it all like the
wolf from uh
from uh pulp fiction the guy who just
came in and handled [ __ ]
lots of cream lots of sugar dead in word
storage
yeah that scene holy [ __ ] oh when i was
done with it didn't look like a [ __ ]
tampon
yeah [ __ ] dude can i give you a peeve
that hit me today please
please give me a peeve so i'm in the i
went to a different sandwich place today
i like i need a sandwich during the damn
big sandwich guy
when i was talking to someone the other
day and she goes i never got into
sandwiches i was like
you're never going to say it's the most
basic thing yeah it's like saying i
[ __ ] hate america
i've never gotten to sandwiches i never
got into movies and ice cream
hate dogs tv not for me yeah
yeah you know uh yeah she but anyway i
go and there's a guy
he's not on speakerphone but he's the
loud guy and it's a small place
so he's literally buzzing in my ear yes
on the loud call
and he's it's never a dude having a
thoughtful conversation on these calls
because they're an idiot they're lacking
awareness right [ __ ]
so what they're saying is never what i
have to i'm forced to listen to is never
something that is interesting in any way
yes yes i literally hear him keep going
i'm different from other people i
invest in the man oh he kept saying that
oh man what a cheese dick
i want to be like i invested in a
machete just now you piece of [ __ ]
yeah wow i would be so embarrassed to
say that out loud
let alone yell it in a store you yelled
it and i it was like the point i was
ordering my sandwich
and i couldn't she was like what and i'm
like oh this like i was so close to
snapping
yeah i was kind of like in my head like
be calm this is his [ __ ]
i gave him dirty looks oh good good the
dirty look is underrated i love a dirty
look yeah
i get a dirty look it it stones me for
like a week i just i'm in the shower
like oh that was a bad look
i gotta change my [ __ ] but no good that
guy stinks i hate that guy i also hate
the guy who talks on the phone like this
yeah yeah all right uh-huh uh-huh yeah
it's like all right just put it to your
ear like a human being who do you think
you are
how about how about the person i'm so
glad we did away with flip phones for
the people that
that would love to hang up and you might
go and just going they would just snap
it they wouldn't even say bye they would
just do like oh you're not ari gold
[ __ ]
hey all right yeah or if they say sam
out
all right we get a seacrest or anyone
who goes anyone who has a thing
speak yeah that guy's the word this is
all very la i picture the bluetooth you
know
yeah my dad and this this sums up my dad
in one
moment one action is he doesn't say bye
on the phone he just hangs
up i [ __ ] hate that and you're like
hey dad like
i'm your son tell me bye you know i
don't know i'm still going i'm still
making up [ __ ] conversation because
i think you're there and then you just
hear like
you're like oh geez dad's gone that is
so weird i know it's it's so
it's so little intimacy just say okay
and hang on no not even okay
he's like well what time am i picking
you up i'm like oh pick uh can you pick
me up at five he's like
yeah i can make five work and i'm like
oh thanks and he's already gone
damn yeah cause he's just like
information it's not mean but he's just
like i got the info
i'm good my biological dad did that
without the phone
[Laughter]
but uh no that's interesting man that's
that's a friend who did that to it and
it drove me nuts
the friend he wouldn't even say bye what
he would just do is
oh no he wouldn't say i gotta go he
would just go okay bye
he wouldn't say i gotta go right you
just give you the hard buy i'm like you
gotta work to the back to the buy
say all right but it i'll tell you
though it also bothers me well i'm
keeping you
let's just say i gotta go yes i hate
that i'm glad
i don't want to take a bit well i know
i'm not i'm keeping you yeah i'm gonna
let you go how about how about i choose
when i go you don't get to decide my
schedule for me okay
totally totally with you so with you uh
how about this one with the phone if
we're on the phone
jeffrey joseph had the funniest joke i
loved and i wish i had wronged
us that guy i love that i saw him in
vancouver last year oh really yeah he
lives there now and uh
wow he actually went to canada he's one
of the few people who said i'm going to
canada he went if trump wins i'm going
to canada yeah
he went good for him yeah cooper's great
oh
we just yeah we just did a whole he's
getting a lot of acting work too he's a
great actor
he's on the sopranos that's right yeah
he's in a ton of [ __ ] he's got a great
resume he's
uh scrooged wow he's in the scene the
sopranos were they handcuffed johnny
sack
that's right at the wedding or whatever
that was yeah wedding yeah
you were farting like crazy you are i'm
bummed that you haven't given rick and
morty more of a shot because you are
you are rick in some ways is he a farter
he farts he belches but he's also really
smart
all right i'll take it so wait jeffrey
joseph he has this great bit about you
always see the guy in new york on the
sidewalk like [ __ ] that guy i'm gonna
but you never hear you never see the guy
in new york on the phone going
uh-huh is that right you never hear that
guy it's always the guy yelling and it's
so true
because every time i walk by a guy going
[ __ ] i'm gonna come over there
and you're like
i think of his bit it's just a sign of a
guy it is funny when you see
an angry person on the phone in new york
when you see someone melting down
yeah it does give you it's almost like
seeing like
it's almost like seeing someone else get
pulled over by the cops
better than me it's weird yes you ever
see someone else stepping [ __ ] and
you're like yes
i'm not happy you stepped in [ __ ] but
i'm glad that you sacrificed yourself
right for the block in a way you know
totally i mean that's the whole premise
of america's funniest home videos
like that guy fell off the ladder he got
kicked by a pony
you know uh the fat guy fell asleep at
the birthday and went through the cake
for sure and like that guy i saw a guy
though snap on the phone
he's like a little jewish guy little
jewish old man he goes you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you listen to me and i was like
oh that just like made my day
that energy just made me happy you piece
of [ __ ] i love it and
it's funny because we talk about how we
hate the guy yelling on the phone but
that guy we don't mind
he's doing it out in the open so he's
going to be if it's in an enclosed space
right
you're a [ __ ] monster that's a good
thing raised you
i don't get that thought process because
i used to work out at the rec center i
love i love the rex
i love the records it's the it's the
best kept secret in the city and
we shouldn't be plugging it you're right
i was just talking let's go to the rec
center
don't i shouldn't have said the price
but you're right it's the best kept
secret me and sally's went to the tennis
court the other day
it's beautiful it's right over the river
no we just went for a shoot but uh i was
like why don't i come here
i should start playing two we should
play tennis like in [ __ ] annie hall
or something i would love that
i'm terrible though i'm terrible too so
it'll be perfect i'd love to get good at
it yeah hell yeah and it's good exercise
and it's right you don't have to run
around too much it's perfect
dude racquetball too that's that's where
it's at we're not successful enough
right now no but i'd like to get there
that's like
gordon gekko it does in college they
they had it in the gym so i got you guys
in new orleans so like we go play and it
was like this is so fun
oh the riley center i only played a
couple times though yeah this is great
it is we got it we got to find a way
dude we got it that's a good idea we'll
do a video there let's do a video are
you good at it no i haven't played in 20
years
but i love that i love that and you get
the
the ball sound it's very tense because
you're in that box
i feel like you feel like we're going to
have like matthew mcconaughey like
energy if we get to do it
that's true
yeah uh what was i saying [ __ ] oh oh
uh the rec center you know you work out
at the rec center i worked out in the
village so
it was a mixed bag of old white people
and like a random colombian guy
and then like a crazy like beaked up
logan paul kind of guy yeah
and this logan paul guy would blare uh
like van halen and whatnot and then this
dominican guy would blare
salsa and we all hated both of them
but they'd be there on different days
and then one day
they showed up together and both blared
their music
so it was like you know eddie van halen
versus uh merengue or whatever the hell
and they were like what are you doing he
was like what are you doing and it was
like the highlight of my life because
i'm like you're both [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're both [ __ ] and now you get to
see it and how did it end
uh one guy was like stormed off and left
and the other guy kept his music and in
his mind he's like i guess i won i beat
the bad guy i'm like
you're the bad guy you just can't tell
that's
oh that's the best you like when the two
like it's almost like seeing yourself in
a bizarro mirror
yes yes you're like oh this guy's an
[ __ ] and then you're like i'm an
[ __ ]
right i i wish they came to see that
though no they're too
far gone as [ __ ] the rude it's like
the rude person on the
on the plane who's like gotta they've
got an important business call
and you're just like all right dude
you're not that special
right imagine if you could get cell
phone service on flights it would be
oh good point dude good point cause
you're sometimes you're on a on a
if you're on amtrak and you're like oh i
[ __ ] up i didn't send the quiet car
and there's just that dude just on the
business calling i know
you're not that [ __ ] important yeah
oh and just attempt
just the attempt to be like hang on man
i'm on the train i got to talk a little
lower
that that's all i need the low yeah if
you even said that i'll [ __ ]
so much respect so much respect that
goes a long way but it's the idea like i
it's my train no one else is on it
i do what i want that's what no i got no
one near me is important go ahead
yeah exactly what do you what do you got
that's what it is
the worst seat you're a bigger guy
sometimes i'll give the dirty look and
they're like
some [ __ ] gave me a dirty look i'm like
god damn it did that happen to you yeah
i've had that before
whoa yeah yeah which now now i'm like i
wish i never gave the look because now
i'm even more embarrassed no you got to
give the look
yeah i guess so it's important to give
they should at least know
get another hand you're you're you're
cracking the armor just a little bit one
day hopefully it'll break but yeah good
point
hopefully well what about the guy who
plays the loud casino game on the bus
you know you hear the the coins you're
[ __ ] on the bus
i guess so the bus is anybody's game a
train and plane
you got to [ __ ] right but when you're
on the bus it's like yeah
subway subway's another one where it's
like i can go on for days about the [ __ ]
like
first off the toenail clippers on the
subway i hope i'm not overstating i
think deserve the death penalty
yes i think and i don't i'm not talking
about a lethal injection i think they
should be beheaded like isis
yeah and then and then i think we should
start with the toes and then cut their
head off
yeah so then here's the other thing the
toenail clippers
the hot meal guy oh don't bring your
[ __ ] halal
on an enclosed space i don't want to
smell your food it's
rude good point good point here here
i love how we said that before the
jerking off yes
the jerking off i can handle that
because i understand that yeah but the
hot food what are you crazy
the hot food is i i at least there's no
smell to jerking off
depends on the season and the shower
situation yeah
yeah you're right all right now the
jerking off is worse but
only a little yeah i'll tell you a fun
story my parents were in town which is
always a nightmare
but they were in town and my i met my
parents for dinner at this nice
restaurant and my mom was late and she
was
she finally showed up and she's like
sorry i'm late there was a guy
masturbating uh on the car staring at me
in the in the in the subway car and i
was like what oh my gosh cause you just
picture your poor mom
and this guy with a huge dong like
looking at her and i was like oh my god
are you okay and i felt violated and
weird and she was like
yeah yeah i just changed cars and i'm
like why are you so fun you know every
other girl is like a guy looked at me
and kissed me on the cheek and i wanted
to call the police and i'm like my mom's
getting jerked off on and she's like
don't even think about it
maybe she took the compliment she kept
moving good points that's how you do it
it is a compliment and she's no surprise
either
i mean she's got short hair crocs red
red frame
coke bottle glasses there was a fetish
for everything that ah good point good
point yeah he had a
better milf thing maybe the thing is
like i like women who look like they're
in arts and crafts
she does she looks like an art teacher
who who makes like um
what do you call those like pot holders
a vase
yeah well you know those like cute yarn
pot holders that can hold a pot
ah i don't know she's very she's very uh
into that [ __ ]
like knickknacks it is i mean you just
gotta move the you gotta move that's all
you gotta i mean it's
a lot you see a lot of people more now
than ever is the people who are just
losing their [ __ ] in public
yeah this city broke people before the
pandemic that's true
that's true i wonder and this is my dumb
theory and feel free to kick me in the
balls here
but i think we're all very our world is
very um
what's the word not meticulated uh
[Music]
oh cat cat kick
calculated no caricatured
what's the uh come on sam thank you
our world is very uh curated okay
thank you you know you got your profile
you got your twitter page you got your
grubhub coming with your order i said
gluten free no
toast you know it's all you you you it's
your world then you go out into the the
real world and it's jerking off it's
toenail clipping it's uh
the mariachi band and i think people
snap a little
for sure it's you have it your way yeah
all the time more than ever
as you said the world it's your you've
curated this is your own little world
right
everything is even an algorithm is based
for your satisfaction
great great great everything is for you
you know
yes if amazon if you like this you might
also like this exactly
that doesn't happen on the subway if you
like peace and quiet you might also like
this guy showing you his butthole right
no
it's not how it goes it's you can't
control the world and
that's what lighting apps even dating
now yeah but for you
but that lack of control makes people
crazy i think
yes for sure but also no one should have
to see a guy jerking his dick
on the train but i mean that's true but
it could be a different thing it could
be the the showtime showtime showtime
guys and
and that's the beauty of life is it's
it's all it's a double-edged sword like
there's horrible things but there's also
i mean you take an amish guy and he's
going to see the mariachi band on the
train and be like
oh my god it's the best entertainment
i've ever seen and it's free
what then he sees a blackberry and he
goes oh my god
well you might be amish you're still
using a blackberry
[Laughter]
dude you know it's like uh it is
madness when you get in the subway like
this is crazy i kind of like that it's
still a mess a little bit that's what
i'm saying i think it's still a good
thing you need it it it levels everybody
like you get a celebrity on that subway
and he's
just as down as you or down as anybody
else
it's fun when you see a celebrity on
there yeah who give me a good one you've
seen
i saw seth meyers on there when he was
doing weekend update like before
the show before this the uh the late
show so that was kind of cool like wow
this is like a new york guy
riding the subway and he's the weekend
update anchor when snl was like still
snl now we just know everybody on snl
and we know half the writer so it
doesn't feel special yeah i saw david
hyde pierce like a few years ago
frasier oh that's a good one yeah very
uh you know very
uh incognito he's got his little glasses
there's a hat down
glasses but it was him that's cool yeah
i uh smoked a cigar on the subway with
bill burr once
what yeah it was crazy uh
not really i mean it was two in the
morning there was seven guys on it but
we just tucked in the corner
we were smoking cigars after a show
amazing night we got drunk at some
mexican restaurant
drank tequila all night was this his
west side yes interesting yeah that
i remember this night when you told me
about it yeah best night of my life
you know one of them and then we we he
got outside he's like here you go and i
was like oh my god we're smoking cigars
we're talking
talking [ __ ] and then he's like ah i
gotta get back to my hotel i didn't know
it was this late
and i was like well i'm going that way
too and he goes oh let's get the train
so we're smoking in the subway we're so
drunk that we didn't even think about it
and we just got on the train
damn and we're just smoking in the train
but it was so late nobody cared so
you're like
part of me was like man you're 52 or
what has he got to be 50 years old maybe
i don't know 49
yeah so if you live like this now i
can't imagine how you lived in
when you were 30. it's kind of fun to
think about
he's a i love it it's cool that he's
such a good guy
because he must know that we look up to
him oh yeah i wrote
the gayest longest sappiest uh message
after because you know you're drunk so
you're like opening up i was like you
don't know what you mean to me yeah you
changed my life i love your comedy dick
i love you
you want me to come over right now i'll
do it
and he wrote like thanks
but he was nice i love you okay
yeah exactly he was cool he was he was
very
uh generous as well and all that he's
the coolest
see that's what people don't get like a
lot of these darker guys tend to be some
of the darker on stage tend to be like
the nicest people in real life
yeah i think that's where they get it
out exactly there's this gustavo bear
quote i think i said it on the podcast
before it says be violent in your work
so you can be ordinary in your life i
think about that a lot
love it get it out there yeah and then
be a decent human
exactly exactly you know it's it's like
tarantino has these people getting their
heads cut off and you know
psycho scenes and blood and he seems
like a decent guy
i was gonna say it seems like he
probably has a bunch of tie hookers in
his hotel every night
yeah but it's weird with comedy i feel
like we we take it on the
chest more yeah it's a weird way to put
it but we take it on the chin more
because
we're just that crazy yeah
yeah who am i odell beckham but give
that a go
you don't get a lot of sport i don't get
a lot of sports references like that out
of you well if you get [ __ ] on your
chest
uh i'm gonna remember you i don't care
about the touchdowns of the
heisman's man he what a weird guy to
lose from he was so
excited yeah yeah well that chess thing
was really uh that was a weird rumor to
get yeah
yeah he didn't deny it but pretty [ __ ]
up
this wine is hitting me nice i love it
i'm bringing i'm bringing another bottle
next week
can we do it back to back wine weeks or
is that weird i don't know i think we
got to mix it up all right we'll mix it
up but
i'm down i just like getting wine drunk
pirouettes yeah this is great
[ __ ] tutti frutti weird name yeah i feel
like a hard-edged guy drinking it but i
don't give a [ __ ]
no no give a [ __ ] if you're judging me
in those youtube comments which mark
will certainly read
that's true and by the way i read all
the new ones it's all about me reading
the comments really
i know you're reading this [ __ ] ha
ha get a life
and i would like it i i don't mind a
ball busting in the comments i'll take
it you know as long as it's not
as long as it's from a good place yeah
yeah sometimes i crack up i'll see
i'll see him on twitter more than than
that obviously and like or
instagram and and uh they make me laugh
sometimes when they [ __ ] on me
oh yeah as long as i can tell it's
coming from a nice that's what ball
busting
is like a lot of people don't know what
ball busting is it's
you you need to tell that the person's
kidding right
otherwise you're just saying something
shitty to another person
exactly yeah yeah and and there's a a
difference between meanness
and joke if you just go like you suck or
you're bad or i hate you that's not ball
busting
that's just being mean ball busting is
some kind of zing
or a twist it's gotta be it's gotta be
from the heart
i was at the cellar the other night with
uh with salaccu so boy we're filming
something
and you know we we roll up with dom also
the other you
did the drones on my last special the
roof special oh yeah and we show up in
joe derosa see this immediately goes
what is this for your sidewalk special
yeah maybe we all laugh pretty hard like
that's how you ball bust that's great
that's that's like you're [ __ ] on me
and there's truth to it but it's
it's not [ __ ] just straight up cruel
that's
yes that's how friends ball bust i also
here's another thing i hate here's a
there's a peeve
oh blood later busting when people are
just
louder than you oh so true you didn't
win because you talked over me
[ __ ]
yes so true i saw a thing on the
internet i'm not gonna say who it was
but this young guy was getting the best
of this
vet comedian and the vet just got louder
and i'm like this guy is actually
funnier than you you just know that and
so you're trying to drown him out
damn yeah it was ugly that's almost like
in a wrestling match where like they've
got you beat and you distract the ref
and you just hit them with the chairs
yeah exactly yeah you stab them no one's
looking
the end of gladiator yeah yeah basically
hold on let me let me give you my peeve
oh boy this is a girlfriend thing
and uh drives me nuts i feel like if we
if we tracked all your peeps they all go
back to
well she's a cute younger lady so i feel
like you know the world has
been her oyster a little bit so you know
i get annoyed with how uh
you know roses and fairy dust everything
is
because i might repair the mortgage but
either way
this is the dumbest thing but it drives
me crazy
i hate a lot of questions because i hate
saying i don't know i feel guilty saying
i don't know so the more questions you
ask
that i don't know the answer to i feel
shittier by saying i don't know
give me an example you know just like uh
hey what was the name of the what's the
capital of turkey
and i'm like ah and i'll look it up
because i don't want to say i don't know
i feel like too many people give you and
i don't know
and it's it's just like kind of a
throwaway like hey uh
what color is your shirt i don't know
and i don't want to be that guy so i
want to be nice
and try to help and say something but
it's weird when people ask
anything when google exists well that's
that's true too but she'll ask me
questions that there's no way i can know
the answer to and i'm like what are you
doing
this is how would i know this what is
this like [ __ ] pop quiz jeopardy
no it's and it's not malicious here's an
example a package will come
for her and i'll bro like oh there's a
package for the gal i'll bring it up to
her you know see
see what it is you know and i walk in
and i go hey you got a pack and she goes
what is it
i don't [ __ ] know it's a package but
it's that [ __ ] all the time
what is it what is it i'm like i don't
know it's a box it's a
cardboard box with your name on it you
open it but i fee
and it's i just go i don't know you open
it the other day that our cat knocked
over something and the other room was
like
and she was like what was that i don't
know it's in the other room like how can
i know that we both are in the same boat
here we gotta go look at it
i don't what was that let me use my
x-ray vision real quick exactly
exactly so now i'm the guy going i don't
know it's so funny that you have a cat
you so don't strike me as a cat guy not
a cat i grew up with cats but uh you got
to see me at four in the morning i'm
making love to this thing i love it
i'm in my underwear squeezing it and
rubbing it and the cat's got one leg up
and i'm in the gut
that's great but all the other parts
sucks you know the [ __ ] and the
litter
does the cat claw up your furniture not
at all we got lucky it's like a great
cat it's never hissed it's never clawed
it's never bitten
is it declawed no just a just a house
cat that's real chill and laid back
damn see if i had if i had someone who
stayed home and took care like but what
do you do when she goes on the road with
you
uh we have a her friend comes by and
they're all like
broke comics so they're like we get to
stay in the village for a weekend hell
yeah
nice and they just take care of you
they're banging in your bed though i
gave one of them the business like you
better not be [ __ ] any disgusting
open micros in here i don't even want
the open micros in my home
and she was like okay okay really yeah
yeah i was just like hey i gotta be
honest about this
yeah i just think banging in the bed
it's like that's your bed that's right
even if you change the sheets there's i
don't like it i don't even like them
sleeping there to be honest
so it's already a push so i was you get
the the cat is that it's a nice touch
you get a little you get a little
it's a nice touch companionship late at
night exactly i love it i would love a
pet
i love in long goodbye elliot cool's got
that little cat yes
it's nice fun a cat cats are they get so
people oh you're a cat guy cats are cool
because to me usually i'm not saying
they're better than dogs
but they're more they're low maintenance
dogs that's what it is
dogs are like walk me twice a day where
your cats are like
oh [ __ ] in this box do your thing right
i like that i like that i can kind of go
away
cats are like cool chicks like you can
just text like you up
that's exactly okay and dogs are like
you better [ __ ] commit
yeah why aren't you texting me why
aren't you texting me you only get those
30 texts and you're like
what are we right what are we exactly
i mean a cat's cool and it doesn't jump
on you when you walk in like a dog does
and you're like all right all right take
it easy it's nice that you're happy to
see me but
give it a second i realize why i have a
lot of relationship problems now that i
like cats
yeah yeah you got to earn it with a cat
cats push you away the whole time
that's true that could be a bit but yeah
cat's great
low energy low key just sits wants to
look out the window
sits on the sill and and uh watches tv
with you
there's no they're great animals great
animals and there's so much hate for a
cat
i i don't get i think it just became hip
to hate a cat
i think it did yeah it was like dane
cook you know just became cool to hate
him
but the cat's great everybody likes it
it's nice
it doesn't bother i do podcasts at my
house and the cat just sits there
and listens to us hard to make laugh
though can't get the cat to
laugh but i'll take it but yeah great
cat
you don't want to be a cat lady that's
the problem
it was a cat man better i think if
you're just alone with a cat you get
that rap i don't think it's
it's gender specific really cat lady
gets the [ __ ] but it's like
if you have multiple that's what is the
multiple yeah if you
if you if you just have one cat i mean
[ __ ] who cares it's great you have
multiple pets that's tough
nah cats are cool it's like living with
a pill head you know they just
hang loose they sleep a lot they don't
talk
it's great it's like stephen wright and
uh i didn't have i was just gonna say
that it's [ __ ] hilarious
that's [ __ ] amazing yeah that's great
make it like you you know so earn it
yeah i like it no i'm into it we're
gonna get i know
i know we're gonna get [ __ ] on this one
i know but i like dogs too i'm just
saying
cats get unnecessary hate yes that's all
i'm saying
and i feel like in manhattan i don't
want to abuse a dog by keeping in a
tiny apartment for 24 hours a day or
whatever i was in college i lived with
two guys i remember
and one of them had a dog that he
rescued from a you know it was a rescue
dog
and the dog was abused and i'll say this
like
it was sad it was skittish but you never
had to tell that dog anything twice
it was kind of oh really oh yeah you
[ __ ] were like don't do that i was
like ah i'm like
this dog listens i'll tell you that
that's great
but yeah you do feel better like [ __ ]
abuse animals like who the [ __ ] does
that
yeah that's crazy who who hits an animal
i've seen it
in real time and you're like this guy
it's like being mean to the waiter where
you're like ah you're off it's
i want to [ __ ] fight a dude i know
and i can't even fight but i want to get
in there
yeah it's not good it's like hitting a
kid or a baby
yeah yeah not a fan or those remember
when i was growing up they always said
the guy would blow weed on the dog
or pour beer in his bowl [ __ ] dog
your drug buddy
you get a [ __ ] real drug buddy yes
there's a lot of guys out there who want
to do drugs
don't make the dog do it it's so easy to
find a guy to give weed to
yeah yeah ben love weed what uh do you
have any racks or no
i do but i'm scared to say it because i
feel like they should sponsor us and
maybe give us money so i don't want to
give them a free plug all right so let's
not give it to him all right all right
good good idea okay right after i i have
one too that i think should be plugging
us
uh-huh and i don't want to give it to
him ah i wonder we have the same thing
oh i doubt it mine's pretty obscure all
right
let me give you one more peeve with the
girlfriend and i'll leave it alone i
love it
all right flying the wall here
well you've had many ladies in your day
so you know you know what i'm going
through here but
this is a gal thing so all you ladies
listening
get your [ __ ] together with this one
she i don't know if i've said this on
the pod i hope not but she loves the
whole
oh you're you're leaving i'll leave with
you
and you're like okay you know i got a 5
30 appointment at the doctor so i'm
leaving at five i planned it all out you
know i got my whole day
and she's like oh you're leaving i'm
like yeah i'm walking out it's 4 59 i'm
walking out the house she's like i'll go
with you i'll go i got to go get a
uh some batteries or whatever it is run
an errand i'm like all right
but then that means do her makeup hop in
the shower do the hair
get your shoes where where's my good
shoes where's my heels i'm like i don't
know
and now it's 5 15 and i'm on the couch
watching uh matlock
waiting for her to you know get it
together while we leave because we had
to leave together
this happened in 1992 yes yeah no that's
i
i'm so with you on this one the the the
leaving is the leaving
i'll leave with you is we're leaving now
now you're gonna get up and leave
man it's also like and i'm not even
blowing you women with this [ __ ] but
like
you look great you don't need to take 30
minutes on makeup you look
fine honestly totally and uh
yeah i it drives me insane i remember a
girlfriend once and we had
laker i might have said this on the
podcast we'd get drunk every week on
this
but i had a uh i had a girlfriend we had
lakers tickets like good seats you did
you did tell you this yeah the whole
point is
she took forever to get ready we get
there in the late second quarter and i'm
like give me a [ __ ] break i've told
this for sure
yeah yeah that's brutal don't do this
with
[ __ ] kobe's farewell season on the
line here for [ __ ] sake
oh this is why the copter went down i
mean it's things like this
that's not true that's not confirmed but
i'm just saying like
time is a factor now i sound like the
wolf again for pulp fiction time is a
factor we have to be curt if i'm hurt
with you it's because time is a factor
uh it's just i i respect time i'm like
hey hey
five o'clock that's when i leave that's
what i've been planning all day i got to
be at the doctor
at 5 30 maybe even a little earlier so
like you're being kind of rude because
you're making me late to something but
we are also
very aware of time because we get a set
time at a club
right 8 35 p.m we get there 8 25 8 30
yeah yeah you have to be so that's
almost like programmed me to be
very punctual true so when people are
not punctual it makes me a little crazy
same same and and the funny thing is
people go oh you get there
a little early because you don't want to
miss your set like no i get there a
little early because
i don't want to ruin the show and [ __ ]
up everything and have people not be
able to rely on me
it's more than just missing i don't want
them i don't want the host to freak out
where are you yes
you're just trying to make people's
lives easier whereas most jobs you can
show up you
get there at 10 a.m you can show up at
10 15 and no one gives a [ __ ] you can't
do that with stand up
that's true good point good point i mean
i will say i was at the miami improv and
they were going bending over backwards
like thank you so much for being on time
thank you for not going long i'm like
jesus what kind of comics are here who
was here last week in paul mooney
i know i didn't want to say it but yeah
i mean it must be a lot of that kind of
stuff
and uh they were like oh just thanks
a legend but i remember he would show up
to caroline's like oh usually an hour
late where the host is like i've done an
hour
yeah yeah i know i know great for the
host you get so much time but uh
if you're young but if you're young i
don't know but yeah it's also scary when
you
you don't prepare an hour you're like
i'm sure you're 15 and then like just
keep going you're like all right
yeah i don't have an hour i'm two years
in or whatever yeah but it was a lot of
like mencia
type stuff where he would do two hours
and there's a show after him and
that kind of thing i remember one time i
met the cellar and uh
i'm hanging with like keith robinson and
a few i remember who else was there but
it was like a good group of comics were
kicking it
and uh carlos mancia walks in and he
lost a lot of weight we didn't recognize
him so keith goes oh look it's it's mike
vecchio
like we all laugh it's another comic
who's it like a thinner
yeah guy and then mencia like
it kind of was probably awkward we're
talking i remember years ago
probably like nine years ago or
something
and we're like oh what does a comic make
if they sell out gotham comic club for a
weekend we're all kind of like asking
i don't know and then mencia just leans
over the table 75k
that's that's what i get that's him in a
nutshell and we all kind of look at him
like but we still don't respect you
and then i remember i was like you know
what let me see him on stage let me see
how he is i gave it like three minutes
and it was [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
damn well there you go of course of
course but uh
yeah i just didn't want to say it to a
microphone but yeah well
that ship has sailed yeah i guess so
i've heard some horror stories like my
friend opened for him and he made him
sell merch and didn't give him any money
for it and all that
and then he would be like you're lucky i
gave you some exposure tonight and he's
like
i'm a working comic like what are you
talking about
jesus yeah this was this weekend was a
nightmare and then he stole like four of
his jokes
yeah exactly you're lucky i gave you
exposure i'm taking your opener your
closer and
your jokes in the middle i know it's a
weird business
but uh hey we're lucky to be a part of
it
do we have an ad oh we don't okay just
checking just checking
we might we might have to plug it in i'm
sure we'll have one by then so all right
we'll plug it'll be an awkward cut from
here yeah
hey hey folks we might be drunk is
brought to you by
fireside cocktails love the fireside i
i got two on my bar cart right now and
that's what you made it folks when
you're on the bar cart
you're in the house you're in my belly
fireside is a cocktail in a bottle not a
mixer
it's the whole kitten caboodle get your
favorite cocktail delivered directly to
your door
completely ready to drink just add ice
fireside makes small batch cocktails
with high quality ingredients
that taste like you're getting an
expensive drink from a snooty speakeasy
i keep it on the cart i'm with the lady
i'm like you want a negroni she's like
sure i go in the kitchen
i crack some ice i shake it up i put it
in there she thinks i'm a
mixologist she thinks you're tom
cruising cocktail yes
dude i'm not a scientologist
it's it's amazing you you just pour it
over ice it's perfect for this we're in
the studio we have to bring a bunch of
ingredients here so true
it's nice you poured over drinks you
have a girl over you know you're just
like stick i want a cocktail
you don't have to go and take 20 minutes
right right it takes you whatever but
the negroni's a knockout not an easy one
to get right but they nailed it
i love the negroni love them manhattan
too
might be my second favorite yeah they've
got they got both and they're both taste
great
but uh that's it you know fireside
cocktails as good as it gets
best bars in the world you know and and
this you can enjoy this whenever
wherever they've taken the guesswork out
of it you know
you're the bartender but they're really
the bartender so it's kind of nice
and uh go get drunk on us fireside
cocktails at drinkfireside.com
use the code drunk if you get a 10
off right there fireside.com use the
code drunk
10 off support them because they support
us drink fireside.com
this is this is great stuff if you have
your friends over if you have a lady
over
yes and you just want a quick quality
cocktail and let's be real you do
of course i feel like this fireside mix
it's almost like the air
uh air fryer of drinks you know i want
something top-notch good that i could
never make but with them
now i can do it i love it it tastes
great
goes down great just get ice anybody can
do it
get on it back to the show um
wreck let me think what i have i
listened to brubacher oh brubach
brubach sorry x loved it i've heard him
i knew i knew that music for sure
yeah it's pretty famous yeah yeah i
definitely knew the music but like
take five take five incredible it's i
don't know if you've seen the the ebert
dock
but it's the oh you haven't seen it life
itself it's so good
i was a huge siskel and ebert guy as a
kid oh they were great i mean yeah they
were so
they were so good together and i much
preferred ebert but
oh yeah i think everyone did but yeah
but they were so good
it's great that there were rivals and
that dive bar in chicago
yes oh what's
the tamale guy comes in real late oh
it's got all the caricatures on the
walls
chicago old town hale house that's it
one of the greatest dive bars
of all time great they did an episode
there too the nude photo
paintings yes yes and it's like trump
and uh
bill murray and john candy it's all
these chicago legends in there it's
[ __ ] great
yeah i remember i whenever i was there
i'd be working like adam you know adam
burke
yeah really funny irish guy and uh we
worked and we get [ __ ]
oh yeah house there and it's not
expensive it feels divey the chairs are
creaky the floors are sticky
the best bar and that's a really great
spot
that was ebert's spot tell me about the
doc oh it's great i mean it just it kind
of chronicles the whole show
like he was a writer at the sun and he
just worked his way up and he fell in
love with movies and he was became the
movie critic and then he got the show
with siskel
they hated each other they go all into
that they got behind the scenes stuff
where they're like
cut yeah [ __ ] you don't ever talk to me
like that again [ __ ] you you fat piece
of [ __ ] he's like all right whatever you
suck you're a hack and then you're like
whoa they show all that
and then uh cisco was kind of a uh a
badass by the way
outside the show yeah he was like at the
playboy mansion big big coke guy
yeah weird fun you wouldn't know it he
looked like some dweeb poindexter guy
with the suit on but
but they end up being friends in the end
they end up being friends in the end and
they
i guess both got cancer crazy well eber
or cisco and ebert
great cameo one of my i think one of the
most underrated shows of all time
every episode is on youtube yes you
haven't seen it the critic
yes so funny my name is elle brooks and
i think it was mike reese and
uh al jean from the simpsons simpsons
guys yeah but it's
two seasons and it's [ __ ] one of the
best pilots for a show
ever it's brilliant yeah just killer it
was too smart
i think for for the because everybody's
like oh i love the simpsons but this i
don't get because it's all references
[ __ ] john lovetts dude killed it just
gold
yeah so good uh yes thanks that show
deserved more so it's on youtube you
haven't seen it you know what [ __ ] it
that's
my wreck this week watch the pilot on
youtube oh good
it's on youtube it is one of the most
perfect pilots because you get who
everyone
it there's a duke phillips character
yeah who's he's the boss he's this rich
ripped
[ __ ] yeah but he's it's almost like
if you like jack donaghy on 30 rock alec
baldwin's character you're like this is
like this character before that right
right but he's like a southern boy yeah
yeah and it opens this is how he's
introduced a woman walks up to him she's
a reporter she goes duke phillips you're
a captain of industry
you're incredibly wealthy you were great
in bed last night
that's how it opens and he just goes i
have no one envy
i envy other people having me to envy
name a better way to introduce a
character yeah
killer killer john lovis was great
they'd [ __ ] with all the they'd make fun
of everybody on the show all the actors
yeah uh it was so good so of its time
too so 90s
great show and there's a cisco and ebert
episode in season two
yeah it's pretty fun but like god damn
it there was almost like family guy
before family guy they didn't
cut away a lot of cutaways that's so
true and it was darker and it was
it felt a little more adult than other
cartoons
and they [ __ ] on movies oh yeah if you
like movies you'll like that there's
like a marlon brando thing there's yeah
orson welles orson welles the face yeah
yeah the fish sticks so good but [ __ ]
i don't know if younger people will even
get the show because it's so many old
references but
that was back when movies were like part
of the zeitgeist it was part of the
world like you'd go back to school on
monday be like you saw jurassic park oh
my god you know it was all part of
the world now now it's like oh yeah what
was that is that on hulu
i don't know i don't have hulu and it's
all different now now it felt we were
more i don't know we were more together
as a country i think a little more but
now we have we're all splintered it was
like
you got your podcast you listen to that
i'm reading this book what do you what
channel is that on oh i don't have apple
tv you know everybody's got their own
thing now
yeah it's funny i was just in the apple
store and it's like they're showing like
that morning show thing i'm like oh this
show looks good i'm like well i ever
watch it probably not
probably not it's good this is like a
good show yeah it's like supposed to be
about like matt lauer
right that type of vibe steve krell's
best oh yeah that is a good show that
does sound good
never gonna watch it probably never not
gonna watch it but multiple people
hanley just told me it was good okay i
hear ted lasso is amazing i'll probably
never watch that
problem with apples they have like six
shows they're like subscribe and you're
like
you guys have you've heard of netflix
hbo amazon and hulu right they have more
than six
right you got to build a catalog here at
least buy something get family ties on
there just so you have more [ __ ]
jesus that's why youtube is always the
number one for me it's like the critic
larry sanders i can watch every siskel
and ebert ever on youtube it's amazing
yeah yeah the cisco neighbors are cool i
remember watching one i would watch a
lot of them
i love their midnight they do a great
review of midnight run but i remember
when casino came out yeah siskel
shits all over it yes and ebert's like
are you out of your mind like
name name 10 better movies in this i
know but you can't even give us a good
review
he pulls off the whole well it's
goodfellas again it's a little bit too
similar and you're like i know but it's
still good
yeah it's funny i remember dating
someone and i showed we saw the irishman
first
yeah that was the only score stacy movie
she'd seen ooh right
yeah so then i think irishman is pretty
good yeah i like it
i like it but compared to his other [ __ ]
yeah but then she saw a good fella she's
like oh this is good
i'm like yeah right then she's a casino
she could i can't do it
she's like it's all the same movie uh
that's that it's so not true it's just
the similar actors and the similar cuts
the voiceover and
and then like and then you know
everything ever since tommy was a
good fella yeah that's like that's like
four movies good point good point
ever since i still love them all but you
can't deny the similarity
right what do you think so scorsese do
you like when he would do weird movie
like do you like after hours
i love after hours how about uh king of
comedy
love king of comedy same i love them
both yeah i like i like any movie that
has some
some style to it like it has a vision to
it you know which
i don't really think you see anymore
there's so much marvel [ __ ] we keep we
always go back to movies in the spot
well we love movies yeah this is like
this is like an unofficial movie pop but
that's cool i mean we talk about a ton
of other [ __ ]
yes but like we're we're observational
comics
we love movies we love comedy it's gonna
come back to that
but i know i remember salaxie was
telling me like you were talking you've
talked about this
you were doing a new orleans after-hours
style yes
you need to do i could see you being
that type of character where you're out
all night in new orleans and it's a
wacky i could see horrible [ __ ]
happening to you
where you're like the kind of buster
keating type of cat where you're like
you can't control
the craziness going around you and
you're kind of like the the bad [ __ ]
happens to you and you just have to deal
with it
yeah yeah yeah totally and that's what
the guy the guy was watching after hours
he's a fan of
my comedy he's like this is a movie and
he just called me i didn't know
who he was and i was like i like it are
you doing it we're gonna do it yeah we
found two guys to write it they love the
idea and they're writing it right now
damn yeah that's a great idea who knows
we'll ever sell it but uh
it's a work in progress you know how it
goes we got to make our own [ __ ] man
yeah we got to get creative we got to
hustle and
it's uh it's a little exhausting but
it's worth it
yeah we're drunk and we're but honestly
man like i'm so happy like i'm seriously
just getting back on the road and i'm
well i'm so happy to be back
it's great to be back and it feels like
you have purpose again you're like oh
this is what i'm supposed to be doing
i just don't know how to write without
torturing myself like this because
i think the thing is if i don't force
myself to do this many sets i'm not
going to hate myself for not having
enough new [ __ ] and i'm not going to
just have it
yeah i need to fall ass backwards in the
jokes dude yeah same that's the weird
thing about
creativity is you can't really for you
can force
getting a joke to be better and
rewriting and tweaking but you can't
force an idea
yeah an idea has got to just hit you
when it hits you it's the worlds have to
the stars have to align you're in the
shower you're like that's it
it's about the [ __ ] you know and then
it all comes together
and but you can't really feel like ray
leonard good fellas the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] what does he say carrot no
what's he
he's saying so they pulled the heist off
the loose hanza yeah
yeah yeah true heist by the way what do
you think
um yeah it's weird how much jokes hit me
in the shower and i think it's because
it's like one of the last places we
don't have access to our phone
i think it's so phones become fully
waterproof it's over
oh god don't even tell me that i've
already put my phone on the side of the
the wall and like play a podcast while i
shower i'm like god
i'm an addict yeah it's it's bad i'll do
music sometimes i can't do
i'll do like i'll do jazz sometimes i'm
like i can't do words right now unless i
need like a pump up
i need a boost and i'm about to do a
show yeah jazz is the best i'll tell you
another man here's a wreck for you
sales that's the name of a band sales
s-a-l-e-s great just
chill music not high energy not too low
but just like great background hangout
kind of loungy music it's almost jazzy
but
but a little more poppy rocky it's great
i'm gonna listen to it check out sales
if you want some low-key just chill
music
i'm pumped i want to hear it have you
listened to oscar peterson too from last
week you're like oh yeah i gotta
if you like broodback you'll like him
i'll do an oscar peterson
i'm a big pandora guy so i got all my
stations so i'll just make one
i haven't done pandora forever i'm old
school i like pandora
i stick with it i hate the ads but i
like that it mixes it up a little hey
that was like two dollars a month no is
it it's got to be 10.
is that breaking your bank well i don't
want to put a get a credit card
out fill it in oh you got the qr code
wrong or the cvr
whatever the back i don't know i'm
horrible at filling anything like this
is going to take you
less than a minute everybody says that
it's kind of like a cooking show they go
oh it's so easy to make a quiche you can
make this in 10 minutes and i'm like i
crack an egg it lands on my foot
the oven doesn't work you know uh the
paprika goes everywhere
it's never easy is this yeah i don't
know man i try to sign up for robin hood
they're like we're gonna process your
[ __ ]
that that's you the stocks the app the
stock app
i was like i'm gonna buy some crypto i'm
gonna get some dogecoin and uh take over
the world and 20 minutes later i'm like
i need a bank statement is this a bank
statement no
that's my social security is exhausting
it's exhausting then you forget the
password and it's a nightmare
we're so like you're like me and that
anytime you're not
doing something comedy related or
working on stand-up you feel like you're
wasting time
i'm wasting time and i'm not good at it
i'm the same way if i'm not working on a
bit
or working on something that is joke
related i'm annoyed
the same way that's why i tweet so much
because i'm like all right this counts
as a joke
and i feel i just kind of relax for a
second it's a horrible way to live but i
guess it
right it creates work yeah we're broken
yeah that's why the the ladies hate us
we produce fun work but uh should we do
emails
oh yeah we'll do uh do an email this is
what uh this is
basically the patreon you email us we
read them we comment we
riff we chat we chop it up send us your
peeves your wrecks
your drinks anything you've got yeah we
should wrap it up soon
okay peeve from corey reeves oh good
rhymes
when two people sit in the same side of
the booth at a restaurant
and singing happy birthday to an adult
at a restaurant
i'm okay with the booth i mean i'm okay
it's your booth
you're here yeah i'm fine with it
i'm definitely fine with the booth
sitting but i the here's where i go i've
been drinking
here's where i go with the uh the
birthday thing
i prefer a man
i like a guy the the exact correlation
how much i like a guy
is to how much he celebrates his
birthday that's a good point if a guy's
like all over his birthday it's my
birthday coming up uh we gotta go crazy
we gotta do this i'm like
you're dead to me if a guy's like you
know it's my birthday today i'm like
i love you and also if it's like a
birthday we were like hey let's just get
like a do like
lunch with four people that's like a
great birthday why would you like that
30-person birthday
so it's true i've never been a big uh
people that celebrate their birthday
you know what though we're also we get a
lot of attention
uh we're kind of i mean it's the same
reason that you and i never want a big
wedding
haters a big birthday uh
we get enough we i mean we do stand up
every night it's kind of like people are
applauding and birthdays are going to
stress us out way more than a show
people like i'm here and we're like [ __ ]
all right
deal with this over here this guy's from
summer camp this guy's from school this
guy's a comedian
i got gotta work on all three you just
work in a room you're like kill me
it's a nightmare i never want a big
birthday great point there's an episode
of seinfeld where they're all in jerry's
apartment and kramer's like oh birthdays
are the worst you gotta talk to
everybody all your friends are there
that you don't even like and jerry goes
yeah every day is my birthday cause
they're all in his house
it's a great joke but yeah it's so true
birthdays are hell and we get a ton of
attention and i was always like why do
people like a big wedding
it's a nightmare it's always something
bridezilla her hair's on fire she's
running you never look happy at the
wedding
i'm happy have you seen them by the end
of the night they're just like
get me out of here i know it's like a
[ __ ] hostage video
i know then they always end up in like
the office of the building and they're
like oh god i need a minute i'm like
that's my whole life
you in that office that's your next
special side do i need a minute
hey that's not bad it's not bad i need a
minute
the 59 of them are horrible i need one
good one
but yeah oh i had a point yeah the
birthday thing if you celebrate your
birthday too much another good title
what i had a point i had a point i lost
it but yeah the birthday guy
who can't who needs to celebrate his
birthday i'm like come on man
you're right it's a small gathering
let's get lunch let's hang out
it's my birthday week oh that's a red
flag
the fattest part of my ass it's my
birthday let me let me come up
with seven excuses real quick it's your
birthday week
shut up what do you think about a
destination wedding i mean it's
i'll never i mean it's crazy by the way
it's a destination wedding if i have to
buy a plane ticket i don't care if you
live
in another state it's still a
destination that's a great point but if
you do it in like
we're getting married in rome i'm like
oh cool go [ __ ] yourself i'm happy to
lose this friendship
right brian unless unless you don't mind
if i don't go if you they don't mind i
mean look that's your wedding that's
your day if you want to be an
extravagant
uh twad yes enjoy it yes they're both of
you
great special but yeah i'm with you
rome like also no gift the flight
was a gift yeah i can't bring you a uh
uh
you know a charcuterie plate or whatever
the hell a mixer you know or a blender
i went to rome yeah that's it i bought
you a toaster i'm gonna throw it in your
tub
it's a restoration hardware you're gonna
like it for two seconds
while you roast uh yeah i hate
hate uh i hate it all i mean i feel like
it's been done to death but i i
really hate a destination wedding yeah
but you're right though people
don't ever get that attention so this is
their moment
they're special but then it's funny it's
like the way we get
smothered when we're at a show and we're
like [ __ ] here that you could see it
turn for them where they're like this
was going to be great and then there is
a moment at that wedding where there's
like [ __ ] this is annoying oh yeah like
imagine if you did a show and like it's
annoying already the groups of friends
you have to like kind of divvy up
and figure out to make work right
there's always that friend that you kind
of have to look after
yeah there's some friends that come out
and you can kind of be like all right
well they can figure it out they can yes
they're charming they can shoot the [ __ ]
they could work a room but there's one
friend who like just hangs on your arm
[ __ ] i'm babysitting now dude this is
crazy and then you know
add your grandmother and aunt and
your whatever your partner's family to
that it's way harder
way harder and i'll throw this out there
and this is going to rust
rustle some feathers but russell ruffle
russell crow ruffle feathers is uh
the people who we talk about how i much
i hate people coming late people come
early is also bad yeah like the guy
i had a a video shoot last week and my
friend i said he's like
i'll be at your house by 9 a.m so i said
all right 9 a.m it's pretty early but we
got to do the shoot i get it we're
starting early
going to get ahead of it calls me at 8
10.
oh my god i'm in your neighborhood i'm
like ah those 50 minutes are so precious
i need it's eight in the morning i need
every minute i gotta milk it you said
nine a.m i planned on 9 a.m and i told
him that he was like i get it you said
9am so i poor guy had to walk around and
get a bagel but
poor guy you should have planned his
time better i know
you're a poor guy thank you i appreciate
that
you're a good friend get a [ __ ]
oatmeal [ __ ] yeah
yeah get an orange juice and a coffee
i got 50 minutes and i'm gonna meditate
were you ever gonna fall back asleep
no god no i can't fall back my sleep
schedule is
a disaster same same i slept till 10
today and that was like a miracle i
either wake up at like 8 45 or noon
there's no middle ground it's
it's gotten dark well the booze doesn't
help the sleeping the sleep cycle
booze is horrible for sleeping it's yeah
you ever had food
and melatonin and you're like i just had
a dream i was getting stabbed by like a
bunch of little monkeys like this can't
be healthy
they're just like stabbing you like oh
and then you wake up and you're like
oh three hours that was rough you know
what that means your mom is smothering
you love the guy with the dream book oh
i had a bit i was working on about this
oh really it hit
monday hadn't been hitting but it was
about now it was about how um
did i ever tell you this joke mm-hmm um
[ __ ] we gotta do a bit jesus maybe like
maybe that's the one i'll do i wonder if
i've done it on here
um let me look i love facial recognition
by the way this saves me all the
passwords just the face i'm like thank
god
isn't that nice i don't i just do the
finger i don't know oh the finger's good
too
that sounds weird it does sound weird uh
yeah this is like having it i had a i
dream about dead rodents
and i looked what up i might have done
this on the pod before but i've never
heard it
but it i mean you're also drunk it's
just that i looked up and said could
signify new beginnings that's what dead
rodents could be i'm like cool could we
get a different delivery system yeah
right
right like i just had a dream about
babies getting stabbed in the face like
romantic possibilities await
that's great have i done that on this
harry i've never heard it very good
that's funny i'll bring it back i was
gonna drop it i glittered at will's city
winery show on
monday and i was not doing great in that
head i'm like all right we got him back
that's one good thing about doing a lot
of sets you're like let me try this
super old bit
that was kind of shaky and then boom me
fix it boom
uh is this anything um so
excuse me i was doing a bunch of racial
material at a show and uh
this black guy yelled out he goes you're
white what do you know about racism
and i i rift i was like well i think
we're the best at it
and we got a huge laugh what's that we
invented it yeah like we
we're the best at it we're an ex i'm an
expert what are you talking about like
which one is it are we you know racist
or we not know anything about racism
so i i see his point obviously but i
thought it could be a fun joke
like what do you know about racism well
i think we're the best yeah what do i
know i'm an expert what did michael
jordan know about basketball
right i don't know seemed like he kept
winning at it yeah
yeah exactly not that i like michael
jordan i mean he's black
but yeah um could be something there
racism yeah there's something funny
about this bit
i hope so we uh we invented yeah we
we're the best at it yeah like uh we're
like sous chefs
you know we're going um that's a little
like it's like wine you know
i'm like online where you're also trying
to not do it but you but like
but you know that you guys are
hmm it's a it's an interesting joke
because it
it's teetering on a couple different
things like if a chef was trying not to
cook something
right right yeah yeah
we're great at it's almost like rambo or
something like that where like
you got to come back out there and like
you're the best man you're the best
we're like no
i shouldn't i shouldn't like no you're
great at this you know when they have to
pull the
the commando out of the log cabin in the
woods
because he's too good we need you
there's got to be something about
getting rid of it though like
like uh hey you're trying not to do it
maybe other people are doing it because
you don't want to make it about you you
wanna make it about other
like it's almost like it's
like you're a chef and that's the brunch
menu you're like this is
we're not proud of this but that we this
is ours
this is kind of our leftovers oh
interesting this is leftover from
yeah yeah that's like left over from the
other generation you know you kind of
right
maybe make it about like past
generations we're trying to get rid
we're trying to ease
we're trying to wean off this but we
still need to get
we still need to get customers yeah no
no
maybe it's it's kind of too i mentioned
this last week like frank abagnale is
great at check fraud
but he's like i'm trying to stop they're
like yeah but the fbi wants you
so like i could go in and help you know
in a way like i'm good at this horrible
thing which is
immoral but but you're not good at being
racist
you don't want to make it like that i
think that's wrong with the premise like
you don't be like you're not a racist
guy
no so so i think you
you don't make that part of the bit i
think it's got to be like
like i'm good at it and everyone's like
what what right right it's got to be
like
um hmm yeah it's it's
it's tough because we're we're the best
white people are the best
at right so i would say historically
we're the best i don't
make it about now aha that's good
historically we're the best at it i mean
check the history books
yeah we're working on it right right
there's a lot of documentation of us
what's something we're killing working
on
think about what we're working on what
are we working on uh
climate change uh it's kind of like
obesity
oh we're doing our best but every once
in a while you see a guy and you're like
who
that ain't good all right the only
problem is no one ever says
either way it's in florida that's not a
bad tag
all right i'll noodle but that's a good
historically is a good good
way to go with it something there i
wouldn't make it about you as my only
thing because you're not racist so don't
make yourself the butt of the jokes just
for the joke it's not sure
i think uh there's something here though
for sure
yeah but what do white people know about
racism i don't know if you read a
history book aha
we know a lot yeah it's one of the rare
jokes we don't know a lot about
receiving it
right right oh that's like we're like
pitchers and you're
and everyone else is like catchers right
we're throwing heat yeah we're batting
a hundred or a thousand yeah no that's
good
it's one of the few jokes where you
don't want to make it personal most
jokes are better when they're personal
no this is an observational joke
definitely observational
um make sure to email us we might be
drunkpot at gmail.com
leave us a review on apple see mark and
myself on the road i think
this is coming out yeah later so i just
came out of cleveland i guess
this came out see me in spokane seattle
added shows
uh salt lake uh lancaster pennsylvania
arlington virginia
uh [ __ ] all over man i i got a lot of
dates coming up raleigh
go to samrel.com shows there's a lot of
dates added just added
um just out of atlanta for later this
year and just added columbus as well so
adding dates but uh
go see me and mark where you gonna be
man hell yeah that's some good good
cities you're going to
i'm going to be at uh magoobies in
baltimore come out to that lord knows i
need you
that can be a tough room hardcore funny
boner okay well that's a tough one
[Laughter]
virginia beach i've never been to in my
life that could be interesting
uh helium and portland that'll be fun i
love portland they're in august i can't
wait
i got family and friends there i can't i
can't wait great town
syracuse toledo kill yourself in
syracuse suicide capital of the world
yeah houston port uh
helium and philly and uh buffalo whew
dayton i'm visiting like the ironworks
union here i'm going all the blue-collar
towns
i'm doing all these rooms too i'm doing
i'm doing helium
uh philly and buffalo too but later in
the september and december i think
oh there you go oh man i mean the bray
improv that'll be a treat that's
is that great oh it's orange county it's
just beach and beautiful people then
you're like why are you laughing you
guys have everything you're
gorgeous am i crazy to so it's like soho
apps
no no but they're they're good they
laugh what is it weird
i'm going um i'm on the road like every
weekend this year pretty much is that a
mistake are you gonna go crazy on the
road should i take wait wait the whole
year pretty much until christmas
i think i'm i'm i'm close to being out
every weekend of the year i have like
maybe four weekends open through the end
of the year
i would hold off on those just to just
to stay sane i mean i
i don't go i'm not going the whole you
know i got a vacation at one point
playing with the lady and you want to be
able to go to a wedding if you if it
pops up i don't know that
you want to go to a wet afternoon you
just said i don't want to go but i'm
gonna i
you know i got i got a friend getting
married and he already asked me like
please block this off it's in august so
i blocked it off
i know it's a nightmare i'm already
dreading it it's five months away
but i'll go he asked me directly you'll
be miserable the whole time of course of
course that's what they're at
when you ask a comic to go to your
wedding you were saying do you mind
being miserable
and that's what i say to him about
getting married but
but it's in boston i'll suck it up
whatever it's one night
out of my life one night it's nothing
yeah and it's important to him
and the wife you need you need to go
yeah for your good friends if it's a
good friend
it's a good friend so i'll be there but
uh
yeah other than that i mean maybe maybe
i'd say okay
but i think about like september october
you're gonna get a little burnt
i'm gonna get burnt but i also i'm like
it's hard to say no man it is it is
it's been a rough year it's hard to say
no to [ __ ] totally and we got a lot in
the tank we got to get it out but
it's good money and it's uh
i don't know i don't mind the road but i
like it too but we're
we're not like everybody else in that
way that's true that's true
we're we're drifters you know we we're
married to the sea as they say
married to the city yeah that's what joe
listed about us right
i know yeah we're married to the sea he
nailed when he said that i was like oh
man that would that hurt so good
you're right there's a couple married to
the sea
guys out there and they don't seem happy
but uh as long as we keep an eye on it
it's like drinking don't think we'll
keep an eye on any of it
we'll keep an eye on you thanks for
listening guys here here
see you next week